Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar.
Did you know that one dollar actually equals one cent?
I know what you're thinking: you're going to tell me that one dollar is equal to 100 cents.
But mathematically, 100 is equal to 10 squared so this is equal to 10 cents squared.
Therefore this equals to 0.1 dollar squared,
and since mathematically 0.1 squared is equal to .01,
this is equal to $.01. And point zero one dollars is 1/100 of a dollar which is exactly equal to one cent.
So there you go: one dollar is exactly equal to one cent.
And by this logic,
Verizon finally has a proof that $.002 is equal to point .002 cents.
Now, of course, this is just an April Fool's joke.
This false proof comes from the most common errors in undergraduate mathematics,
written by Eric Schechter who's a professor emeritus of the math department at Vanderbilt University.
And no doubt you'll be able to see where the mistake is in this false proof,
because every single math teacher has seen a student submit a proof with this kind of error.
Can you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video. Please subscribe to my channel.
I make videos on math. You can catch me on my blog Mind Your Decisions. If you like this video you can check out my books,
which are linked in the video description and you can support me on Patreon.
If you have a math topic you can email me presh [at] mindyourdecisions [dot] com
And you can catch me on social media either at mind your decisions or @preshtalwalkar.